all of these workers are owners of the
business dispossesses the West Oakland
farm my name is Elaine Brown I'm the
former leading member of the Black
Panther Party and I'm the CEO of a
nonprofit called Oakland and the world
enterprise
I haven't given up on the principles
that I adhered to back in the days when
I was in the Black Panther Party one
thing we did right here in West Oakland
is we start a program of gardens in the
ghetto believe it or not and secondly of
course as everyone knows we had a lot of
food programs because we recognized one
of the greatest needs of the poor is
food
people who have formerly incarcerated
looking for work a lot of times we don't
get hired because of our background if
you don't get a feel for the chance to
get out and prove yourself and show that
you have a work ethic you kind of like
left it fend for yourself out on the
streets you know go back to dealing or
whatever which I'll choose not to do
this site in the next several years will
be built up to create a model for the
country to recognize that people who
have gone to prison have got to have
some pathway to earn a living and they
can't keep getting denied on account of
their previous incarceration I have
something to look forward to when
someone asks you what are you doing I
was like I'm a co-owner of a garden out
in West Oakland and so I'm happy about
that
like I love to cook so